avec nous Christiane Bergevin
administratrice de société conseillère
stratégique chez Roland Berger qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs à toutes les
semaines dans notre seat Christian
dergevin bonsoir
vous nous avez dit il y a quelques
semaines que la personne qui va succéder
à sophie Brochu sur une grosse pointure
est-ce que c'est une grosse pointure
pour vous
j'ai plutôt dit une grande pointure
d'accord
et vous savez je salue en fait le choix
qui est fait et je suis en désaccord
avec ceux qui ont été bien avaient
peut-être pas le profil requis pour la
santé énergétique je vous donne deux
exemples il était à la tête de la Caisse
de dépôt qui était un des premiers
investisseurs mondiaux à s'engager dans
la démarche de SG l'environnement
social et la gouvernance et à des
invités du de tout le réseau de tous les
investissements possibles comme vous le
savez surtout donc il y a un leadership
c'est un niveau des grands investisseurs
qu'on dit pour transformer les pauses
pour aller faire une économie plus verte
deuxième exemple dans ton rôle au
ministère des Finances bien il y a deux
grands outils la décarbonation du Canada
vous savez que les émissions des
lumineux on a parmi les plus grand les
plus importantes émissions dans le monde
alors comment décarboner les taxes sur
les investissements vers mais aussi
voler du changement climatique pas
besoin de faire un dessin on voit de
juste ma dernière semaine les
catastrophes qu'on a climatiques au
Canada et finalement doivent être
améliorés avec l'environnement durable
finance de ça alors donc tant que
vraiment le profil
requis pour cette mais il a donc vous
vous lui voyez un profil énergétique
quand même pour occuper cette
fonction-là mais est-ce qu'il est là
pour ça parce que c'est un poste de
gouvernance il y a plein d'experts les
meilleurs experts du monde entier dans
le développement de l'énergie propre
sont au Québec on s'entend je dis sont
au Québec mais il y en a beaucoup au
Québec quand même il peut s'appuyer sur
cette expertise donc est-ce que c'est
davantage le gestionnaire qu'on va
chercher
un surbigné c'est celui qui s'occupe des
tourbines c'est un lit deux de grandes
sociétés d'envergure mon dans le domaine
d'énergie et s'il y a une chose pour
avoir été elles sont conseils
c'est un visionnaire Michael Célia et
c'est un homme qui est engagé dans le
développement de la société les
politiques publiques vous avez montré sa
carrière et en plus là il y a quelque
chose on a parlé de tellement raison
comment c'est important pour le Québec
vous savez qui était assis à la table
grand argentier il y a déroulé le plan
de sauvetage de Terre-Neuve l'an dernier
en 2022 en Terre-Neuve a eu des enjeux
qui ont été importantes que au dernier
projet qu'ils ont réalisé donc un
milliard qui était constante sur le
gouvernement canadien et celui qui était
à la table c'était ma côté bien ça fait
certainement de lui quelqu'un qui a un
réseau de connexion parce qu'on y en a
mondialement il y en Ontario il y en a
planétairement l'homme des situations
appuyé par des équipes qui devront être
Michael c'est bien à la réputation de
travailler fort de tout lire d'apprendre
rapidement également
mais ce que c'est un homme qui écoute
qui entend qui s'entoure est-ce qu'il va
écouter les experts les meilleurs
experts
mais ce qu'on a vu de lui au niveau de
la Caisse de dépôt vous savez quand il
était arrivé à la Caisse de dépôt il y
avait vraiment une reconstruction à
faire il y a pas beaucoup de gens qui
auraient ce job là il est engagé
plusieurs experts et les autres
certainement écouter
du risque alors il y a pas tout simple
pour moi que Michael c'est quelqu'un qui
sait écouter maintenant c'est un homme
qui est exigeant vous l'avez dit pour
ces équipes il boulimique de travail il
tente entouré d'une équipe rapprochée un
petit peu moins inclusif que l'épée
sophie Brochu qui par ailleurs je dirais
au niveau de la pédagogie de la
communication avec certainement été une
centaine extraordinaire
au niveau de la communication
elle avait cette pédagogie
qui change qu'il était pas
nécessairement pour la première ligne
mais chacun trouve sa recette et dans
son corps était entourée d'une équipe de
communication lorsqu'il est à laquelle
qui était très efficace et puis c'est
sorti c'était plus rare mais alors je
m'attendrai ce type de leadership mais
on sait jamais on change avec les années
peut-être ce qui est aussi mais
peut-être plus difficile alors
finalement si je vous demandais de
résumer un peu ce que vous pensez de ça
pourquoi pierrefitteben pourquoi
François Legault qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent de Michael Sevilla
je pense que comme il le fait à la
caisse on a deux Baudelaire au Québec on
a la caisse qui alimente le régime des
rentes puis on a Hydro-Québec qui nous
appartient pas en faire une société qui
dans cette transition certainement
génère plus de bénéfices pour l'économie
du Québec
a grandi si on parle d'installation
pénomes sont parc d'installation puis je
l'espère continue d'offrir une
tarification
raisonnable à la population du Québec
donc un grand leader qui a négocier des
attentats incroyables qui amènent cette
société là qui est déjà parmi les débuts
mondial un autre niveau c'est sûr que le
rôle deck c'est les contacts et
capacités de négocier sont incroyables
je pense qu'il va s'appuyer sur une
équipe d'exécution il devrait qu'il y
ait les derniers grands projets au
Québec date un peu qui devra être
renouvelé donc cette transformation je
l'espère il se refaire communauté avec
laquelle merci beaucoup Christiane
Bergevin pour cette analyse ce soir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]